don't do it now chris sims is already
contemplating grabbing my leg and
squeezing it as hard as he can he's done
it all the time i've got scars there
from it i dare you to do it to say juan
parker
i know i can't that thing is unreal just
seeing it here it's unreal all right i
mean i talk about legs a lot it's
important important for good football
players and you're still like the king
of the world as far as legs are
concerned uh yeah i think so right yeah
i i work hard uh a lot of people love my
legs i get a lot of compliments on it
yup um especially more than once i got
to nfl um i mean i kind of have the same
ways i had in college but uh i guess
when odell uh called me stay qualified
and it went to a whole nother level what
kind of like i mean what kind of
what kind of stuff we doing are you
still doing like big weight well you
like get underneath 450 500 pounds and
squat that way ah that's what i'm going
to get back to this year you are i kind
of got away from that last year right um
but
uh yeah i'm getting back to that that's
that's kind of i think i've been talking
to talking to my strength coach at the
giants and my trainer with ryan um
getting back to you know not crazy like
how i was in college but um that's
that's how i got to where i am yeah
that's who i am and um why turn away
from me i turn away from a little bit
but let's get back to it and i want to
you know try to improve it and i believe
what you do in the weight room and
especially when you do your lower body
in the position i play uh translates
right to the football field yeah saquon
how long does it take after the season
ends for you to feel like you're you're
back to normal that you've recovered
from what you've just gone through uh
for me i
i got hurt i got hurt early in the year
so um i was struggling with
recovery in the beginning and i guess
you could say in the middle of the
season but uh at the end of the year my
body started getting better and better
so uh you know unfortunately we weren't
we weren't good enough to be a player of
contender but if that was the case uh i
felt like i was training upward um with
how my body felt getting my speed back
getting my strength my balance back um
so right now i feel really good and
that's why last year i took a little
break off um obviously with you know
there's a lot of traveling and you know
sometimes you do take a little vacation
i just came from a little vacation but
even on my vacation uh making sure that
i do something active and stay active
and um you know still have that that
mindset just continue to try to get
better even in the earlier stages of all
seasons how do you process in your mind
as you're going through a season and you
know you've got an injury that for most
guys they would take some time off and
get better before they come back
how do you how do you get yourself
what you did keep going through it keep
fighting even though you know you're not
at the level you want to be because that
injury is keeping you from getting there
yeah you know for me it wasn't that i
wasn't at the level i wanted to be um
you know in my mind i kept telling
myself i was at the level that i wanted
to be um i kept telling myself i wasn't
hurt i kept telling myself don't worry
about it uh trying to have that that
mama mentality yeah and that was right
you know that exactly that was like my
mindset to go into it but then um i had
to go back and reflect on myself and see
uh especially when we got into the bye
week and see like what's going on you
know a lot of people could make excuses
and a lot of people could say this and
say that oh you know he's not having the
same production because he hurt or this
and down the third but um i didn't want
to take that stand so i just kind of
just went back uh watch film myself saw
that you know i just gotta you know i
got to bring it to another level um and
that's what my team expects for me and
then uh kind of got back into my groove
going later into the year things seem
like they're on the up and up all
together with the giants i mean
especially with you and daniel jones i'm
pumped i'm a giants and you know that
right i mean tell me at the moment tell
me something about daniel jones we don't
know what was the moment you knew like
okay this guy's got something he can be
he can be special
you know i think you go to practice and
you see him in games and you know he can
make throws he can make the runs uh he
can do all that stuff but you know it's
kind of off the field for me at least
right um you know i remember he had a
little he got banged up a little bit and
he's coming in at five o'clock in the
morning because he don't want anyone
even though he's banged up yeah um he
just have that mindset he's one of the
first ones in one of the last people to
leave obviously he had you know a great
mentor in front of eli manning
but
it's hard to find at a young age and
it's i keep saying young age like like
i'm not you're an old wise man
but um you see that in him and that's
the reason why i know that and i don't i
don't think i know he's gonna be one of
the best quarterbacks in the league take
away talent take away all that god-given
ability just off the you know the
mentality and the work ethic that he has
and if you continue to have that um the
future is going to be bright uh for not
only for himself but for new york giants
does he remind you of eli like the way
he acts and handles himself yeah i would
say that i mean he definitely definitely
i would definitely say he he reminds me
eli but um you know at the same time
there's two completely different players
and two two different complete uh people
but uh the mannerisms and the way that
they carry himself and yeah the way you
got to be in new york you got to deal
with the media the way he responds to
the media right um and you know uh he
can have a great game he's still going
to come in and and do what he need to do
same like eli or he can not have the
game that he would love to have and
still going to be that same guy no
matter what seemed like eli so i see a
lot of similarities and saquon even
though you've only got two seasons in
the nfl you got to mature quickly in
professional football because things
change fast and now you're the guy that
is the only thread back to when you
arrive because the quarterback's gone
the coach is now gone joe judge has
taken over what do you know about your
new head coach what can you tell us
about him so that we can anticipate how
this year is going to go yeah i'm
excited very excited um not just only
with coach judge but with all the
hirings with coach garrett and from all
the coordinators and especially for me
personally with what i wrote our new
running back coach but uh you know i got
to sit down with coach judge and you
know what you can expect is that uh i
know he said in an interview that um
we're going to be a team that you know
we're not going to lose football games
off of uh you know details or mistakes
we're going to we're going to make sure
that we're focused we're going to come
in we're going to harp on the little
things um and you know he's going to set
the mentality for the team and you know
set the standard in the culture and you
know it starts up there with him and
then it goes down to me and to dj and to
all the other leaders and then and so on
and so on and trickles down um so we
just all got to buy in and believe in
and i think that you know from what i've
from what i've seen so far and obviously
we haven't been in otas or practicing or
and haven't seen a playbook yet um but
just having a conversation with him and
you could just see the way that he looks
you in your eye when you're speaking to
him um that he means that he's about
business and um you know i love that and
i'm truly truly excited take yourself
out of the equation who's the best
running back in the nfl right now take
myself out of the occasion um
i don't care about the year you had or
not i know you're one of the best and
thank you you know
we both would agree there me and mike
i mean do you look at derek henry dave
henry finished the season off so strong
that's kind of hard not to not to say
him but um i must say christian
mccaffrey yeah you like mccaffrey's game
i'm gonna say he's he's just all around
um you know i trained with him his work
ethic is is amazing he's he's a freak um
he can catch the ball you can run the
ball in between tackles uh outside of
tackles he can pass block he can do it
all and yeah i think that's kind of
where the game is evolving to and or
where the game is at right now right
running back right um i think
you know
after the season he had this yeah i
would say christian mccaffrey but uh the
way derek henry finished the season off
um he's definitely uh he's up there he's
up there for sure yeah how much do you
plan saquon to talk to a guy like
ezekiel elliott just to get more
information about jason garrett and
playing in his offense uh yeah i'm
definitely you know i i know zeke pretty
well i'm definitely gonna hit him up or
you know get it probably down here in
miami and get a time to talk to him and
chop it up but
i don't need to talk to zeke to know how
uh coach garrett likes to use the
running back so i've got to see for two
years and got to play against zeke for
two years obviously in college too but
in the nfl and watched a lot of film on
those guys because you know i've seen
the same division we play a lot of teams
and um you know i love the way that they
use not only not only just zeke uh you
know zeke had a great years dear dak
amar cooper um
all those slot wire receivers yeah the
tight ends right you know i think the
real
the offense is really good and i think
what we have and the scheme and the
talent that we have um you know
sky's the limit but uh obviously you
gotta come back to like i said with
coach well coach judge is gonna set the
standard and come and make sure we're
focused and detailer in it and um also
gotta find a way to stay healthy yeah
tell us about old spice man what are you
doing spice yeah allspice i'm here with
old spice with the ultra smooth new line
um you guys know me you're ultra smooth
exactly ultra smooth i'm a low key guy
um and they got low key sense
they got deodorant face body wash the
face body watch is actually
dermatologist tested
which is you know a lot of people can't
say that and um you know i've used the
product i love the product and uh it's
in stores and shelves now so make sure
you guys go get that yeah no i'm a old
spice guy and i did this yesterday with
alvin kamara too because he was here
again i am gonna do it again i'm gonna
open this up so i smell good i'm gonna
dab it on my because i feel like i'm
getting a little sweaty under there all
right so i'm doing that okay you want
something i still no i don't it goes on
the inside i don't know how many times i
have to explain i was so confused for a
second right now what do you think i was
gonna take yeah i was like how are we
gonna do this but i'll tell you it
wasn't a fluke yesterday with alvin
kamara this is the new old spice look
the darker i like it sure yeah even this
one
it's an upgrade i like spice next level
with saquon barkley well i want to know
we got to get who he's going to pick in
the super bowl too you got off the hook
we want to pick i want an mvp saquon mvp
too yeah okay yeah that's that's
something new i haven't got that yet um
okay
the chiefs are amazing patrick holmes is
picking the niners yes arguably the best
player in the nfl him and lamar jackson
uh after the season right um
but we're up against the first yeah
hurry up defense wins games defense when
championships yeah you gotta run the
ball so i would say 49 who's going to
win it
george kittle all right here we go
some of your time good luck next year we
continue on tv right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports